IS NOT ENOUGH BECAUSE
$10 MILLION MAKES NO IMPACT ON
THEIR SCHOOL.
THEY WANT $30 MILLION,
$40 MILLION, $50 MILLION.
JOINING ME FROM THE ANKLE COME
EXCLUSIVE DR. DREW PINSKY.
THEY WRITE DOCTOR TO THE STAR.
>> Drew: I THINK YOU FOR NOT
READING THAT.
DR. DREW, WHAT TURNS A
HELICOPTER OBSESSIVE PARENT, YOU
AND I BOTH KNOW THEM INTO A
CRIMINAL.
>> Drew: YOU KNOW, SLOW, YOU
DON'T REALIZE YOU ARE GETTING
INTO IT.
I THINK YOU WILL APPRECIATE
THIS.
THE COLLEAGUE OF THE AMERICAN
MIND AND THE AMERICAN CHILD, ALL
LEADS TO NARCISSISM.
WE HAVE HAD NARCISSISM 30, 40
YEARS.
WHEN I WORKED AT PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL COME ALL KINDS OF
PERSONALITIES AND DIAGNOSTIC
SPECTRUMS.
THE MID-90s, CLUSTER B, 100%
OF THE TIME.
SO NARCISSISTIC, BORDERLINE AND
IF YOU ARE A PARENT, YOUR CHILD
IS AN EXTENSION OF YOU AND YOU
CANNOT STAND TO SEE THEM
UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU HAVE TO SEE THEM FROM EVERY
DISCOMFORT, WHAT THEIR
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE YOUR
ACHIEVEMENTS AND YOU HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THEY ACHIEVE COME A
FREAKING MESS.
>> Laura: PART OF THE PROBLEM
KIDS SEE THEIR KIDS AS A STATUS
SYMBOL TOO.
>> Drew: AN EXTENSION OF THEM.
>> Laura: YOU SEE JANET DOWN
THE STREET A LACROSSE PLAYER GOT
A FULL RIDE TO DUKE.
AND THE KID IS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT, YOU KNOW, RIGHT GRAMMAR
STRUCTURE ON A PIECE OF PAPER
AND STRUGGLING, WHAT DID I DO
WRONG?
AND THEN THEY SAY, THERE'S GOT
TO BE A SHORT CUT AWAY TO GET
THROUGH THIS, RIGHT?
>> Drew: THIS IMAGE THAT TELLS
YOU IT IS A GAME WHICH IT IS A
BROKEN GAME AND A GAME THAT HAS
SOLUTIONS IF YOU JUST FOLLOW HIS
ADVICE, YOU CAN FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY.
ONE OF THE THINGS I LOVE ABOUT
THIS STORY, THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO
USE THE BEST OF SORT OF STRATEGY
FIRST HAND HOW.
YOU TALK ABOUT WHITE PRIVILEGED,
OLD-SCHOOL KINDS OF BEHAVIORS.
THEY USED THURSTON HOWELL TOP TO
BOTTOM HERE.
HOW THEY COULD NOT HAVE FELT
GUILTY ABOUT IT I CANNOT
UNDERSTAND.
LAURA AT THE THING THAT HAS ME I
WOULD IMAGINE, PSYCHOLOGY.
>> Laura: TALK ABOUT THIS.
>> Drew: SOMEBODY IS DOING
PSYCHIATRIC TESTING ON THESE
KIDS AND FALSELY MEASURING THEM
TO HAVE DISORDER, ON THE TEST
THAT IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
>> Laura: ADHD.
ADHD.
AND IT'S --
>> Drew: I'M INCENSED BY THIS.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: THAT IS AN ISSUE AND
THERE ARE PEOPLE WITH REAL
DISABILITIES THAT NEED HELP.
>> Drew: YES, ABSOLUTELY.
EVERY TIME THEY GET HELP, PEOPLE
JUST LIKE THEM, HOW DID YOU GET
IN?
EVERY TIME A KID NEEDS REAL HELP
WITH EXTRA TIME ON THEIR TEST OR
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE --
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK WE HAVE
TOO MUCH ANXIETY?
THAT'S WHY I REALLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT POTBELLY PIGS, SNAKES.
>> Drew: PEACOCKS.
>> Laura: HONESTLY, PEOPLE ARE
ABUSING THAT.
REGULATIONS TO BRING IN A MANNER
OF ANIMAL ON A PLANE AND USE
THEM AS AN OTTOMAN AND THE SEAT.
>> Drew: SO MUCH IS GOING ON
TODAY, HEY, IT'S ME.
HEY, IT'S ME I'M SPECIAL AND I
GOT MY FOOT IN THE DOOR AND HERE
IT COMES.
>> Laura: ISN'T IT GOOD TO LET
YOUR KIDS THEY'LL?
>> Drew: LET THEM FAIL.
>> Laura: I LITERALLY SAY THIS
TO MY KIDS, I'M A 12.5-YEAR-OLD,
TEN, EIGHT AND YOU DON'T WANT TO
DO YOUR HOMEWORK, OKAY, GOOD
LUCK.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LOOK TO ME
TO BAIL YOU OUT.
>> Drew: A BOOK CALLED THE
COLLEAGUE OF THE AMERICAN MIND
AND IT'S WELL DONE, BUT I TOLD
MY KIDS LIKE YOU WANT TO DO
DRUGS AND ALCOHOL?
GO AHEAD, TRY.
>> Laura: I WILL NOT BAIL YOU
OUT OF JAIL.
>> Drew: COME DOWN, IT AN
ADULT, GIVE YOU THAT ALCOHOL
BECAUSE I WILL CALL THE
SHERIFF'S LAUGHING MY OFF WHILE
I HAVE THE KIDS HOLD.
>> Laura: TO CRUMBLE BECAUSE
WAITING FOR THE SAFETY NET.
>> Drew: WE ARE THE PROBLEM,
THE PARENTS, NOT THE KIDS.
AND IF WE DON'T LET KIDS
STRUGGLE WITH THE MISERY OF
LIFE, THEY DON'T DEVELOP
REGULATION, THEY ARE NOT
RESILIENT AND THEY DON'T DO
WELL.
>> Laura: THE OTHER DAY, MOM,
I'M BORED.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
I SAID, GO PICK UP A BROOM.
I'M BORED.
PICK UP A BROOM.
PICK THE GARAGE UP.
IT IS SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON,
THANK YOU THE NARCISSISTIC
PERSONALITY TRAIT.
STAYING ON THAT.
>> Drew: WE'VE HAD A TURN.
PEOPLE ASKING WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING?
THAT IS WHY THIS IS HAPPENING
THIS NARCISSISTIC TURN AND WE
COULD GO ONE.
WE TALK ABOUT BILL CLINTON.
>> Laura: ON THE RADIO.
>> Drew: A LONG TIME AGO.
>> Laura: THIS MAKES IT WORSE.
>> Drew: WE WILL LOOK AT THIS